there are architects and there are
gardeners an architect will need that
blueprint to build what it is they're
going to build he said I'm a gardener I
plant a seed and I tend it and nurse it
and I watch it grow
my outlines are about 25 pages to 30
pages long even if I go in thinking that
I know what it is I'm still gonna end up
figuring it out three sequences in the
first act
six and the second act and three and the
third act of equal weights when you're
trying to problem solve instead of
telling the most compelling story that's
that's what I hate about outlining it's
probably 50 60 70 percent of the work
you do because it makes the load a lot
easier and you can write a faster
screenplay if you have a good outline
but my body my brain just goes just
right it it's right here just right it
what is it that lines up
I usually have a complete full outline
and then jump into the story so I'll
have a really specific idea of the
objective of every single scene you
should make outline make your character
break down so all these things that you
like do and make your cards you plot out
your story or first and second third
I'll do any of it
I will say one thing that I think could
be very interesting to people that are
writers is is what I do is I outline a
script very meticulously and my outlines
are about 25 pages to 30 pages long and
then when I go to write the actual first
draft I will not read one word of what
I've written until I've written the
whole script so for my first pass on a
screenplay I start from the beginning
and then I just go and I go all the way
through until I'm done without having
read one word of it and it takes about
three weeks so in three weeks I've
written a whole draft and it's a lot of
fun because there is no judgment
whatsoever I'm just writing straight
through and then I go through and very
meticulously work through the scenes and
that takes two to three weeks and then
in six weeks I have a draft but it's
really two drafts because I've done one
straight through and then one this sort
of meticulous work through and I will
say that the second phase of it the
meticulous work through phase is the
least enjoyable part of the whole
process because it's the most critical
where it's just for a couple weeks it's
just I have to work through these scenes
and and and but I just do it and then
after that I have a draft to work off of
and then there's many drafts after that
but it's it's I have this nice
foundation I'm pretty thorough with my
outlining I tend to I'll spend quite a
bit of time outlining before I even
write the full like I usually have a
complete full outline and then jump into
the story so I'll have a really specific
idea of the objective of every single
scene and ultimately it saves me time
when I first started writing I was anti
outline I kind of had the attitude you
know it's the young attitude of just
like you know I'm just gonna write and
my my guts gonna tell me what's right
and what it's meaningful and stuff like
that and that works for a lot of writers
but I noticed that I would hit a lot of
dead ends and I became emotionally
attached to those dead ends and then it
became really hard to rewrite until I
just drove my stories off the
and so little by little the more I you
know honestly that Ron Media 24-point
thing was huge because it was so simple
you could literally sit there and just
plot out a story in an hour and you'd
have a really good idea of where was
going and then from there you're you
know that's to me that's when you go
from like you know discovering your
story to actually becoming craftsman or
a class person where you're working on
the story and taking control of it and
then you start to take a step back and
then you know it's almost like a render
machine you're rendering your story
before you ever sit down and write it so
then the script really just becomes kind
of a secondary artifact of all the work
that you've put into it so yeah it's
been a lot of time outlining it it's and
it's you know a lot of people feel like
it takes away from the creative process
usually that's kind of the writer saying
well I want to be in the audience too
and I want to experience and be
surprised by it but outlining doesn't
take away from that because what happens
when you sit down like you've outlined
you've got your outline right here and
then when you're writing you put
yourself in the moment you're you're in
the skin of the writer or the character
and you you're experiencing it and then
if your gut tells you to try something
different try something different see
where it goes
so you're still you know the whole
Gardner versus architect the pan servers
a plot or kind of thing I call it what
is it the bee assassin versus the
Berserker basically the idea that like
the the planner versus the person that
just sees what happens next
and I think it's important to to
understand the consequences of the
choices you're making
but the whole process of writing is an
experiment art is an experiment and the
out the only thing that rules it is do
we make it emotionally resonant for
somebody else and as artists we get to
decide how much that is like how how we
build that relationship if we want to do
it as a lit for a living then we become
responsible to those people that are
investing in us and that's that's when
you want to be able to to have control
of your craft
that's when you want to be able to you
know climb the mountain know how you're
gonna get up there cuz you gotta meet a
deadline you know it's there aren't a
lot of producers that are gonna be like
alright you know we needed this three
months ago and you're still just kind of
wandering the weeds but a lot of the
process of writing is experimenting in
the weeds going into the weeds and then
stepping back and the trick is just not
not panicking when you're in the weeds
and saying okay this is part of the
process let's step back and look at the
let's look at the outline and see if
this is gonna work so for me it feels
like it's like like a map you're zooming
in and you know you can do the the
street view where you're in the
character and you're just driving along
and you're like yeah I feel this I'm
going through this Street and that's
when you're writing but then you pull
back you zoom out and you see the
overview of where you're going and
that's the outline well for me on these
assignments that I do they're usually 10
or 12 pages and it's the entire story
treatment and it's not just line by line
I mean there are somehow lines it's just
it's a line in line but for these movies
for television they're a tax so
everything has to be broken down
but I wrote it as a story so if you were
to sit down and read it you'd be reading
the story of the movie which i think is
essential to create because i find that
many in fact i've had friends that do
this so i'm just gonna sit down and i
have the vague idea and i'm just gonna
write and I'm like you'll you'll be lost
in the barren wasteland in fact - with
no water you'll be in the desert you'll
be lost and you'll wonder how you're
gonna trudge through those 75 pages or
whatever I'm a huge advocate of outlines
before starting writing and I know it's
it's probably 50 60 70 percent of the
work you do because it makes the load a
lot easier and you can write a faster
screenplay if you have a good outline
now that doesn't say there's room
there's no room for changes or
improvising but if you don't have a
solid roadmap going in it's almost like
a pre draft of a first draft and I'm not
an advocate I know there's people say
that about the vomit draft or just spill
it out but
I don't have the luxury of spilling out
on my assignment jobs I don't I really
have to turn in let's say out of a ten
scale I've got to turn in probably an
eight an eight you know out of ten
because I'm now holding up development
you know and I've also done rewrites on
other screenwriters work projects that
have that were to page one rewrites
which means that the script that they
have went through multiple drafts and
still is not there and they have a buyer
they have a network who's waiting on the
script and so I've also been hired to do
rewrite job where I can come in but it's
like a page one rewrite where see the
script that you have you can't use any
of it the names yes the concept yes but
you basically and that's that's
something that I've learned how to do
which is good because there is a lot of
rewrite work out there and and some
writers look down on it upon oh you know
but but an example is that I took a
rewrite job and that ended up being
three more jobs with the same company
because that opened the door for them
and then they were thankful for that so
you never know what opportunity is is
gonna you know you're gonna either turn
down or accept so but back to your point
about the outline I think is extremely
important to do an outline before your
screenplay because it's easier to work
out the problems there than it is
writing a complete first draft and
having just have so many problems and
also a trains your like I said it's a
it's like you're an Olympic athlete it
trains you for the time when you do have
to do outlines because I'm not allowed
to write these assignments without an
outline that I have to create so they
won't just let me go to pages they mean
they have other people involved you have
to okay it so the outline is extremely
important generally what I'll do is I'll
start with the premise line and I'll
write out a premise line sort of
basically for me like the foundation of
the script a couple of sentences take
take you know let's start to finish and
then I'll expand that into my no maybe
two three four pages there's a sort of
writing in section
so I'll divide it into into three
basically if it's a movie three movie
acts but you know in more in quarters so
it's like the equivalent of a quarter
quarter quarter quarter which takes me
through the four quarters or the three
acts of the of the movie so it's I can
keep it because one of the things that
happens when you start writing it for me
and when I start writing out and at
writing an outline in you know prose
form is that you know if you don't if
you don't from me if I don't kind of
stop you know stop writing at a certain
point you know you end up with let's say
your outline is for pay you're writing
it just outline at four pages the first
two pages may really only be the first
quarter of your script because you know
you you know you end up writing so much
and then then you have to really then
ultimately you end up with kind of you
know disproportionate disproportionate
acts so basically I'm just trying to
write it as tightly as I can y'all write
it long and then I'll then I'll edit it
but in the end I want to end up with
kind of four relatively close
descriptions of each quarter okay let's
say that's that ends up being three four
pages whatever then if it's on if it's
an assignment then I'll then I'll give
it to the executive or whatever I'll get
notes on it rework it and then if it's
not for me I'll do the same thing for
myself and then what I do is I divide
the and this was a you know really I
have to credit writers boot camp for
this because they're really this was
kind of the way they taught me how to do
it and how I always do it now and I
taught other people and I I think it's
pretty it's it's one of those things
that's just sort of like I don't think
it's on an uncommon way to do it but it
kind of boils it down to I think a
really effective way of doing it is that
you divide I divided up into twelve
sequences three sequences in the first
act
six and the second act and three in the
third act of equal weight so basically
you know if you're writing a hundred and
twenty page script or you know it's ten
page as a sequence if you're right if
you're more like 100 page script it's
eight or nine pages of sequence and I
feed out the list of scenes so I'll take
a right turn I create a sequence
sentence you know so this is sequence
one two and three so added that sequence
sentence that I write right out pulled
from the outline the longer
line I then write a list of the scenes
that will comprise that that that that's
sequence so I'll put like with the
scenes in a row and then I'll figure out
how many pages that scene will
approximately be so that I can add it up
add up each sequence and say at the end
those six scenes will equal eight and a
half pages or something and it's an
estimate it may sometimes I'm very off
but it's an estimate and this is just my
kind of organized way of doing it you
know and how I don't get lost in the
process
you know and I really kind of stay on
track this is just mine everybody has
their way of doing it and so I do that
so ultimately you end up with basically
twelve series of single obscene lists so
and which should eat ultimately when you
add it all up should equal you know
whatever your page desire page count is
one hundred hundred and five pages under
twenty pages an estimate and then I take
that I put that on to my final draft
that lists on to my final draft and I
create a slug line over each one you
know interior living room night exterior
you know baseball field date whatever
and and so I have the line and then I
you know the what the what the scene is
about and then I have the slug line so
basically what I end up with is a whole
written script except with that dialogue
essentially and then you go in and just
you know you craft it and to me it's
just it's a very step-by-step process so
it's like an accordion you're constantly
expanding that accordion until you have
the whole script written so that back
that that works for me but everybody
does it differently there's a step
outline there's a there's a one sheet
which is just a one one sheet of paper
which is the concept you know it's sort
of a short synopsis there's the logline
which is even smaller you know two or
three sentences so there's different
steps and and you have to have you have
to have each along the way because you
have the quick pitch I'm not interested
then you have the quick pitch and they
go hmm I'm willing to read something not
the script but I'll read a synopsis then
you know there's different steps of how
how interested they are to read what you
want is the final product the final
script is for them to read but the the
treatment
I mean there's many different for you
know again like a step outline I've done
outlines that were 30 pages I mean
completely just you triple it and you
have the script but everything had to be
worked out because it was a very
technical the way the film was gonna be
shot was from from like an iPhone and
from different things and so really had
to be spelled out you know there was no
because on the set you just can't leave
it up to chance so that's you know but
at their that point I could have written
the script in weeks because it was all
figured out you know I figured it out
already and you want that outline for
those dark periods when you're stuck you
don't want to be stuck trying to figure
out plot points when you should be
filling pages that's the worst part
that's the worst place to be
I will if contractually obliged to doing
a beat sheet or an outline I will do it
and sometimes you are and what usually
happens is you spend all this time on
this beat sheet in this outline and it's
the most bastardize thing in the world
because it's not a script it's not a
story it's kind of this thing that
exists halfway between a script and a
story and I will but I will do it if
contractually obliged to I'll do an
outline and I'll do a very detailed
outline and I'll do it always to the
best of my abilities I won't slum but
I'll do it and I'll hand it in and the
producers will go we love this outline
this is a great outline now go write the
script and you'll go write the script
and you'll have your outline you'll say
okay here's what the outline is telling
me and you'll start writing and it will
immediately start changing and better
ideas will emerge and the next thing you
know the outline is completely out the
window and you've written a script and
you'll turn it in and the producers we
go we love this this is just like the
outline and everyone's forgotten the
outline and I don't I know again my
Beach it is I obviously you kind of know
the beginning you know you're putting
your characters and you feel these
characters and you put them in this
situation that they're gonna have to
fight for their lives to get out of I
kind of know what the end is gonna be
kind of sort of and then it's the great
unknown and to do that in a beat sheet
to me it's just taken all the fun out of
it so don't don't don't listen to me you
listen to all the other people out there
who say outline beat sheets please if
that's what you need to do and there's
great writers who do that of course they
do that but and and sometimes when
you're collaborating it becomes more
necessary because you're sending stuff
back and forth but for me I I they don't
work for me and anytime I do them
everything starts changing anyway so
much that that they quickly become
irrelevant this is how terrible
there are things you're supposed to do
as a writer that you should do you
should make outlines make your character
break down so all these things that you
like do and you make your cards you plot
out your story or a first and second
third I'll do any of that
none of it yes that's the guy who does
it all correctly I don't know any of it
I like to sit and think about the idea
and then I like to think about the
character who that woman or man is and
what they're like and what their world
looks like and then I just start to
think about what the movie might look
like in my head and once I sort of start
seeing the movie itself in my head then
I start writing it I don't know how it's
gonna end necessarily unless it's a
thriller if it's a thriller I need to
know how it's gonna end
so I can know where I gotta go if that
makes sense you know because you always
want to have that ending that people go
call so you think of the ending first
like what would be a cool hall and then
okay now how do I get there so I go
backward if it's a throw if it's not a
thriller if it's just a story about
people in life in love or whatever it is
then I don't really think that much
about what's gonna happen I just sort of
think about the people and where they
are and where I want them to be what the
world's like what they enjoy there's
usually a lot of wine involved because I
enjoy some wine and what happens is I
end up writing I think something that's
much more organic and much more Here I
am a writer and I can't find a word what
is the word organic and
what is it what's what's the word when
something just spontaneous Monday's
organic i end up writing something
that's more organic and spontaneous
because i haven't sort of telegraphed it
and kind of like when you're acting you
know you always hear don't play result
you know cuz you've read the entire
script so your character is on a journey
so you know what that journey is but the
character doesn't know so you don't want
to play like you know what's coming
because you'll Telegraph it to the
audience I find the same thing works for
me as a writer by not knowing everything
when I'm writing I'm discovering it as
I'm writing and it makes the writing
process exciting for me because I'm like
sitting there at the keyboard I'm like
this is great you know what's gonna
happen next
I don't know I can't wait find out
either you know what I mean it's like
it's a spontaneous thing and then
hopefully the training and and and the
laws of inevitability that I try to keep
focused in my head you know kick in as
I'm writing and when it's done it's it's
a really great it's a really great story
but yeah I I like to look at it as a
living breathing story that's unfolding
as if I'm watching it and that drives me
toward the end because I feel like if I
do all the outline stuff for me if I do
all the outline stuff I've already kind
of done it already so now it's like oh I
gotta write it all hated all the hurry
figured it out so I just like to jump in
and start writing it's a like a
discovery you know when when you have
preconceptions of what your story is but
then it develops into something very
different I think there's something very
exciting about that and something very
freeing about it if you allow yourself
to open yourself to that it can be you
know you can go in a direction because I
think even to a certain extent some of
the things that we've done at least in
this screenplay have moved further from
what I thought my original idea was but
it's so much better I'd rather not but
usually that's required for the job like
if I'm getting paid for it they'll
they'll want to know right these days to
get hired to write a script you pretty
much have to write the script like you
have to write like a 35 page outline for
a 90 page script you know turn it in
before you can get hired to write the
script so I when I'm writing for the
people I do whatever it takes to make
them comfortable with it which normally
involves an outline me i I just it's
kind of like for me it's not a musician
but I feel like it's like just jazz you
know I feel when it's time for a change
I can feel when you know we need to know
more about a character and it's like
it's very my way of working it's very
artificial to say at this point on page
12 we need to learn that Charlie has a
secret you know what I mean like because
I don't know what that secret is I'm
like do I make it up now or do I wait
until I get to know who charlie is and
you know write that in and like I feel
like the music of it you I just know on
page 12
maybe there's something he's not sharing
with us what it may be it's this you
know it's just way more organic and I
feel like it flows a lot of times with
outlines I'll find when I'm writing the
actual script I won't feel it going the
way that the outline was you know I mean
so it's either like I do something false
I'm suddenly writing for me a lot of
times especially the rewrite process for
other people's work he's taking a round
peg and putting it into a square hole
it's like here's a movie i this is an
actual true story I had written a film
that was a beach beach sports kind of
romantic comedy that was set in Thailand
the note I got from the studio was great
love it
only now it's in Bulgaria and it's
Christmas huh so my rewrite was too
completely and utterly change the entire
you know scenery and what's happening
right round peg square hole and it's
like it's it's like a Rubik's Cube kind
of problem it doesn't necessarily lead
to good writing right like when you're
trying to problem-solve instead of
telling the most compelling
story that's that's what I hate about
outlining that's why I don't like being
pushed into a corner by some random
decision I made three months ago when I
was just trying to make people feel
comfortable about what the movie was
gonna be does that make sense
I can ramble about it for the next two
hours because I it's something that I
struggle with a lot I'm not someone who
does even even though my very first
successful screenplay was almost like
doing an outline it was like a stream of
consciousness treatment that I wrote and
then I realized after writing like 20 or
30 pages you should just write the
script you it's right here you should
just write the script but that's because
I have been marinating on it for so long
I could just do that but when it comes
to outlines which is a process that a
lot of script writers do and I'm still
trying to figure out how to do that I
really admire people who really know how
to outline and write their scripts from
there and things are just a little bit
more organic for me but I can write like
a beginning a middle and an end but it's
usually about two or three pages of
stuff and a character breakdown I often
feel like if I had the I don't even know
what it is whatever it is that that
screenwriter has that makes them sit
down and discipline do the outline yeah
I think that my job might be a little
bit easier but I'm just saying that
because it seems like that works really
well it's like the studio way of doing
things - like TV you have to give an
outline and then you write the script
and oh I hope tell you a funny story
about that so I was in the the Walt
Disney Fellowship and I was in the
screenwriting version of it they don't
have the screenwriting arm anymore they
just had the TV arm
believe it or not I've been trying to
get them they get the other one back but
I wrote a television script for them and
at the time it was the practice and my
wife and kids where the TV shows are on
television that I wanted to write for
and they were like okay so you have to
pitch us your story do an outline once
we like the story and then write the
script right so I pitched them the story
they liked it right and I was just like
what's this outline man I literally went
I wrote the script then I wrote the
outline from the scroll Wow okay and
then I gave me outline and they're like
this is great they made a couple of
tweaks for the outline so I implemented
the tweaks in the outline and then I
just went and implemented between what
the script was already done it was just
like a formality it was a formality
because that's the way that they had to
do it we had to do it that way but it
didn't make organic sense to my process
really if I'm honest I'm always figuring
it out as as I write even if I go in
thinking that I know what it is I'm
still gonna end up figuring it out as I
go
yeah there's I have inside out writing
and outside in writing and the outside
in will tend to be something where
there's kind of an external story and
then so you're kind of you've got the
container a little bit and then you're
figuring out all of the ways that you're
furnishing and arranging what's in that
container and generating some new stuff
but and then when occasionally I I have
the luxury of doing kind of what I call
the inside out where you just you have
almost nothing you have like you woke up
in the middle of the night with like an
image in your head or you know you're
just kind of this very fragmentary thing
like a grain of sand and and then it's
like you're making stone narrative stone
soup you're like here's the pebble and
then you know do you know the story of
Stone Soup
you know they go around they get the
meat and the carrots and and everything
and then it's more like it's like found
art like just pulling all of the the
things from your life your memories and
what's going on and and you're kind of
building it out from from this little
thing and it becomes something where you
really didn't have much of an idea what
it was going to be at all and so that's
that's pretty fun
and and that would again of course be an
example of figuring it out as you as you
go
I'm a storyteller and and the stories
emerge from someplace that that that is
Beach heatproof that's just me
baby I don't know what I mean they just
they just come from somewhere else and
if I tell it all in in a quote-unquote
beachy it's like it's like why would I
do that to myself why would I why would
I take all the fun out of discovering it
and put it in this thing that's just
kind of bullet points it just but that's
me that and and that's the idiosyncratic
part of me but I'm in good company
Stephen King my favorite writer asked
him about beech sheets there's a but but
you know help me the writer who wrote
Game of Thrones the books thank you he
said at the best of anyone he said there
are now you would think particularly if
you've read the Game of Thrones books
that those things are outlined
completely they're so intricate they're
so full of plot and character and this
needs to overlap and this needs to you
know I mean that they're extremely
intricate stories he doesn't outline and
what he says about it is and I think
it's such a great quote and I'm
paraphrasing a little bit but it's the
essence of it there are architects and
there are gardeners an architect will
need that blueprint to build what it is
they're going to build he said I'm a
gardener I plant a seed and I tend it
and nurse it and I watch it grow and
there are architects who will do that
beat sheet and will do it brilliantly
and and I'm so I'm not knocking it and
then there are gardeners and I guess I'm
a gardener I just kind of let the idea
it there and I tended at night and I
take good care of a
make sure it gets all the water and Sun
and then I watch it grow it does allow
you to write a faster first draft is to
have a solid outline because for me I
have to see the film in my head before I
can write it and I know that I'm I have
a lot of problems ahead of me if I can't
see it I mean I don't I don't lock in
like I've almost seen the movie like you
like when you watch a movie you remember
it I have to see it that way and I know
things are working when I start to live
and you know the outlines good for
living with your characters you know you
get to live with them you get to you get
to see how the movie is working or
doesn't work before you sit down and
write that screenplay which is building
the house you know that's almost at the
pre blueprint and in my opinion that's
been my experience but I know a lot of
writers just want to write down a couple
of lines and and wing it and there's so
many so many things that can go wrong
and why why not turn in your the most
amazing first draft you can I don't see
the problem with that and in fact like I
say you have to when you're doing
assignment work you want the fewer
drafts you don't want eight drafts
because nothing's working you know you
want to turn that where they go Wow
one of my assignments I did two drafts
and two polishes were done that's what
they like they don't like five you're
not getting it that's where you get
fired and they hire somebody else who
can facilitate the notes and get it
moving you know it's it's it's creative
but it's also a business at the same
time unfortunately what I have to I will
but it's very uncomfortable I feel like
my organic process is just different I
understand why it works for people and I
understand why they do it but my body my
brain just goes just right it it's right
here just right it what is it that like
we're wasting time right this grip I
look at like some of the Coen Brothers
movies you know some of the great movies
of our time right amazing stories
incredible character you know incredibly
creative those movies are not all
necessarily how they
but but they don't feel as specifically
structured as most movies you see some
are some aren't I think they take you
know they just they're really brilliant
you know I think they're just able to
you know they're able to infuse their
stories in their own world in their own
structure you know for example if you
can do it it's great I I think I do
I've just seen too many writers who get
lost in the process because they haven't
sort of laid it out enough ahead ahead
of time but again it works for me I I
and I never look at it at any of this
like oh it's it's putting me in a box or
I'm you know using a formula it's not at
all it's just it's how I write and
especially when you're on a deadline and
you you know you have a limited amount
of time to write something it really
helps me you know you know move more
quickly and and having give me a system
of sort of checks and balances on my
material and and kind of force it helps
me not over write as well and ultimately
maybe spend not what lose too much time
on ston any material that I'm not
alternately gonna put in the script I
don't believe in any right or wrong like
there's this one writer bob signs he's
amazing he says he doesn't outline he's
successful writes great stuff he just
wrote extracurricular and it's fantastic
I read the script it's so good and he he
doesn't outline but he knows how to
write he gets he gets where he needs to
go and he knows how to tell a story so
it's like it's right what works for you
is fine the important thing is to be
able to to sell it to the producers to
engage the people that it that that need
to be engaged you're writing for readers
largely
so you want to learn to the language of
what they expect but within that you
know it's it's whatever gets you there I
don't think you have any obligation but
generally speaking the average person
would benefit from taking the time to
plan out where their story's going to go
have a good idea of how it's going to
end and then you know work toward that a
lot of people will stare at the blank
page I've never understood the staring
at the blank page because by the time
I'm ready to write a scene I've already
had like pages of writing I
Kent it's like the slingshot you're just
like slowly like preparing like getting
all the scenes getting the character
getting the plot the conflict you know
what every character wants so when you
sit down you're ready to write you let
go and you're just flying you know but
it's but it really comes down to
everybody discovering their own process
you know and I'm not a purist like lots
of people don't outline and they're very
good writers are very successful and a
lot of that's the intuition or their
experience that informs it